[Music]
you stepped on your wife's dress this
dress will be stepped on at least 30
times the one you gotta be careful this
and it's not a plan but it's a
prediction I thought maybe it was a plan
comes look at that slit if you step on
it too much you know what happens just
my oh no in the masterpiece what was the
react when you you're like honey you're
stepping on my dress
what do you say - oh it's been 11 years
I'm very austere dressed up on a dress
every train she's had up step times I
wanna know about this though you know we
ask all this dress question so look at
look at you covering up what a bruise or
something oh wow what we actually put
superglue in this that get it is that
healthy I don't know I do in the doctor
tomorrow it's impacted for sure
superglue is made for once
well evident I gave her this info today
she believed you know it's military
doctor this is you were the one who told
her to do that huh
yeah look at it look how that turned out
well yeah you covered it up right now
great perfect beautiful it can't be
really I think like me and the rest of
the world can't get enough of your wife
because I mean there is nothing it's the
greatest thing ever happened to social
media she makes me laugh every day every
single day
alright let's talk about Luna cuz that's
all that matters her playing the piano
first how great was that and then she
kind of terrible at Sara she's not good
at it he will do I'm so happy that she
seems to spark up when music is on so
that's that's what start and then
teacher to actually play it at some
point later yeah anything and you know
she will naturally obviously she has
been she has the jeans and her right
she'll have the exposure in the jeans
your mama is actually quite musical
people don't know that really more what
you sing or play the piano you know she
can sing better than you think this is
my father's opinion like you're giving
away my honest opinion I've never seen
her I'm bear I've never seen so are you
gonna convince it or do it do it then
what's that are you gonna convince her
to do it do it we already did it we did
a holiday Target musical together and
she's saying and wrapped on it other
than just the humming what the future
album who knows what the future brings
everybody stop God we love everybody you
are like they win the red carpet come on
they win the red carpet Johnny listen
about I can't sing
[Music]
you